[Music]
school do you realize where we are no
look a real man the clean modernist say
the cool-blue color palette we're in
Mikey oh did you say Ikea nope
I said Falcon Theory just like you
Shaggy and Scooby were taken yeah this
blue light came down from the sky and
beamed them up thank you agree I have to
assume that if they were with their
friends they wouldn't have been
kidnapped
okay can you skip the emotional
punishment there was some guy who almost
Scooby and Shaggy I don't know but I'd
like to shake the hand of whoever
created this and then you know throw
that hand in prison for trying to kill
our friends
[Applause]
[Music]
this mangy stray is coming with me it's
not a stray
okay then what's his name his name's
Scooby middle name doobie last name
welcome aboard
this isn't about some guy in a rubber
mask I would have gotten away with this
and the word for you mentally this is
about one of us
[Music]
turn on the lights
where are my balloons didi when I say
Falcon fury that's supposed to cue the
balloons oh great great timing you might
want to buckle up
[Music]
scooby-do-be-do maybe this can lead us
to our culprit jinkies
apparently he's been stealing Netflix by
using his mother's account that is not
fair for the rest of us who have to pay
for Netflix you have to pay for Netflix
if you go over and drop us off here
I guess our new movie is an origin story
that we heroes should have won
I want the rock to play me
[Music]